hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the leukini
gambit the accepted lines i did a video
on the leukemia gambit not too long ago
got a lot of positive feedback in that
video we looked at the main line which
was not the accepted it is the decline
when knight comes to a g5 definitely
recommend checking that video out at
some time but everyone said hey what
happens if they accept the gambit so
that's what we're going to be looking at
today the leukemia game it starts out
with pawn e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 bishop here to c4
getting into the italian game joko piano
with bishop to c5 and then pawn d3
followed by f5 gamuting this pawn right
here
and so last time we looked at knight
coming to g5 putting pressure on this f7
square in today's video we're going to
be looking at what happens if the pawn
takes here on f5 we are going to be
pushing with d5 every single time this
opens up for our light square bishop to
be involved into the game take this pawn
here on f5 also opens up for the queen
to get more involved into the game
attacks this bishop here controls the
center of the board we now have two
central pawns they only have this pawn
here on d3 uh this pawn here on f5 has
taken our material but we can get that
material back so this is we're going to
be looking at we have a few variations
that we will be covering in this video
the first one is since the bishop's
under attack bishop here to b5 pinning
down our knight to the king then we're
going to look at bishop back to b3 we'll
also look at if they play d4 say hey
we're attacking their bishop they're
going to attack our bishop then we're
going to look at bishop here to g5
attacking our queen and then lastly they
could play
knight to g5 prepare preparing queen to
h5 so sit back hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video on the lochini gambit
accepted lines
so the first variation we are going to
look at in this specific setup because
remember we're always going to be
playing that d5 is when the bishop comes
here to b5 it's under attack comes here
to b5 pinning down the knight and then
we're going gonna play knight two e
seven does a few things one it defends
this knight here on c6 it also
has another attacker here on
the f5 square but it also allows for
black to castle on the king's side they
have a couple options here the first one
is just to take this material here on e5
one of the reasons that they play the
bishop here to b5
is because this knight can't move it's
being pinned down to the king here and
so the pawn here on e5
is a sitting duck now this is a good
variation for black black scores
extremely well here even though they've
given up now two pawns in material black
plays the move castle on the king side
and then they can put a lot of pressure
on their opponent now let's start to
look at the two options from here they
could take this knight what they're
typically going to do they could first
take with their own knight because
sometimes players don't like to give up
their bishops and now we just play pawn
to c6 this pawn's protected forcing the
bishop back here and now we just take
that pawn here on f2 and you're like oh
my gosh we're just giving up so much
material absolutely we are they pretty
much need to take here it goes extremely
poorly for them if they don't take so
after they take here we play knight two
f
five you can see this opens up for the
queen to come here to h4 uh once the
knight moves then it's going to be a
discovered attack the king is in the
center of the board here going to be
very difficult for them to hold on to
this if they decide instead to take with
their bishop i think that's a little bit
better for whites but we're going to
take here with our knight on c6 they're
not going to be taking up here
with our knight on f5 but after they
take then we're going to take here on c6
maybe the castle on the king side we're
just going to take bishop here on f5 so
slightly different setup here we do have
one pawn down a material so you still
need to be extremely aggressive uh
because you you have to keep in mind
your opponent has their rook here on a
one that has not been developed their
knight here on
b1 not been developed you have the
bishop pair and you have all the lines
opens to to start to attack so if you
just sit back and play passive uh your
opponent definitely will win because
they're up in material
so you're playing a gambit to have that
initiative you have it in this opening
so continue to do that and that's what
happens if they played knight takes here
on e5 early on another option is just
say okay they play knight or we play
knight to e7 now they play bishop here
to g5 gets a bishop involved into the
game pins down our knight and says yeah
we can take here you can't really take
your knight back here because now this
knight's being pinned down so they're
really pinning down our knights to our
most valuable pieces the king here and
the queen right here well we're just
gonna castle on the king side as we have
before
and they have options from here they
could take our knights
they could take this knight here on c6
so they could even play something like
pawn to g4 just solidifying on the king
side of the board so we can't take this
pawn because we really do want to take
this pawn so we'll look at each of those
options let's say they take bishop here
on e7 well now we're going to take with
our knights here maybe they tyke with
their knight here on e5 and then we play
bishop here to d4 this is actually a
huge mistake from white it it's a trap
because once they take here they really
don't see the fact that we can play
bishop here to d4
and we're going to win this night
because next move we play bishop takes
here on b2 and we would end up winning
this rook here on a one so we're going
to win this night that's not going to be
the best option for
them another option would be let's just
go ahead and take with their bishop here
on c6 okay we're going to take with our
pawn obviously our knights pin down
we're gonna we're not gonna use that one
they cast on the king side and then we
play rook takes here on f5 trying to get
that material if they decide to hold on
to that material
so instead of taking with either their
their bishops may they play pawn here to
g4 we're going to play queen to d6 now
we do want to protect this e5 pawn uh
and this is a great way to do that it's
also just eyeing down more material on
the king side of the board centralizing
the queen is always a good thing so
that's how you approach it from the very
beginning if they decide to play bishop
here to b5
the next version we're going to look at
is that the bishop just comes back here
to b3
we're going to immediately just take
this pawn back here on f5 so we gave up
a pawn we got that pawn back and we have
a better setup we have the two pawns in
the center of the board we have our
bishop hair here controlling the center
we have a very good setup i think
already black has a solid game here now
they could play maybe something like
knight to c3 they could castle on the
king side so we'll look at both of those
options because i think they're both
logical knight to c3 here let me play
knight to f6 preparing to castle on the
king side you could always be looking to
castle on the queen side but i have
found it better to castle on the king
side plays very similar to
a reverse kings game but if you've ever
played the king gambit my favorite
opening in all of chess you cast on the
king side you do not have your f pawn
blocking it and so all of a sudden you
have a semi-open file for your rook here
on f on the f-file that can really put a
lot of pressure on your opponent so
after knight two f6 maybe they cast on
the king side we play queen to d6 which
is pretty common in this
opening
so that is one variation if they play
just castle on the king side uh then
we're just going to play knight to f6
same as before castle on the king side
as well and remember we should have a
pretty easy game since we are
controlling that center
all right now the next version instead
of the bishop coming back here to b3
next thing is they could just play d4
says hey if you're attacking our bishop
uh i'm just going to attack your bishop
here in the center of the board as well
but we can just take it with our knights
here and if they take okay we can go
ahead and take with our bishop as well
they have a few options they could just
get frisky and play queen to
h5 check
here we're gonna play king to f8 don't
try to push forward with your pawn
things do not go well just play king 2
f8 here and then bishop comes back here
to b3 since it is under attack and then
we play knight to f6 the bishops or the
queen is forced to move and they're
going to be in a tricky spot now if they
don't play queen coming out here maybe
since the bishop's under attack bishop
back here to b3 completely fine as well
knight to f6 we're going to castle on
the king side you can see our bishop can
come here to f5 gobble up that material
we should have a pretty good game here
but you can see this knight here and the
queen now protecting this pond they just
don't have a ton of threats and we are
controlling so much of the board
now typically think in this situation
they are going to be playing bishop here
to b5 or kicking it back here to b3 i
don't really think you'll see too much
of d4 in the center but they could try
something else pretty crazy they could
play bishop here to g5 getting their
dark square bishop bombs to the game
which sometimes they do have a challenge
doing and so from here we're going to
play queen to d6 now some people
i've seen even recommend bishop coming
back here to e7 i really like to keep my
bishop active in the game and not just
come back and play defense especially in
a game if i'm giving up material i don't
like to then retreat on that and just
exchange my bishop here i like it on c5
attacking this pawn here on f2 so i'm
going to be playing queen here to
d6 and then maybe hey bishop here to b5
pinning down my knight then i'm gonna
take this pawn here on f5 now i control
the center of the board i have the
bishop here here things are fine i can
then play knight to f6 in the center of
the board if i want to so that's how i'm
going to attack it if they play bishop
here to
g5 the last one that you could see is
knight to
g5 gets kind of crazy but
pretty easy i think to just go ahead and
take this bishop here on c4 just be
prepared for they're gonna play queen to
h5 that's the whole reason that they're
willing to give up that bishop here on
c4
is to play queen to h5 you cannot be
playing pawn to g6 here it's a huge
mistake because after you do that
they're just going to take here and then
you're going to play maybe bishop here
to g4 attacking their queen but then
pawn to g7 discovered check
you're going to have to play something
like bishop takes and they take your
rook here get a queen it just does not
go well at all so once you see
queen 2 h5
pretty easy here just play the move king
2 d7 looks a little awkward but remember
you just got that bishop here on c4 and
so you're you're okay you're good in
material now you just have to make sure
your king is safe now they have a couple
options here they could play knight to
e6 here it's a great little outpost they
have the pawn here on f5 and they are
using it with their knight here but
you're still fine you play queen to e7
they don't really have a ton of threats
that you have to worry about too much
maybe if they take that material right
here you could take it with your queen
they come back here to g4
attacking this pawn here but then we
have the move knight to d4 threatening
our own you know knight to c2
uh check with the forking here on a2 so
definitely have some good options here
if they decide instead to play
you know queen down here to f7 check
then we're just going to play queen 2 e7
e7 and stopping that yes they could take
our pawn up here but we took that pawn
and exchange it for a bishop i think
that's going to be completely fine
knight to f6 here
and then we can start to get our bishop
involved at some point get our rooks
involved just make sure you hold on to
your king because they will be trying to
attack that the rest of the game so that
is the lukini gambit the accepted lines
i know so many people were asking about
this hopefully this helps as you're
playing the lakini more
i personally like it if they don't
accept it i think some of the lines are
more exciting definitely more dangerous
for white which is always fun but you
have to be prepared if they do accept
that you still have a lot of good
options but understanding them
knowing the best ways to continue are
always valuable so thank you guys so
much for watching if you have other
videos you want me to make feel free to
let me know in the comments below i'm
always looking for new videos that you
guys want to see but thanks again i'll
see you guys in the next video
you